hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start
warning spoilers ahead today
i'm going to explain an intriguing and
mind-blowing science fiction movie from
black mirror seasons 3
called hated in nation the movie starts
with a journalist
named joe powers walking towards her
house when she receives a gift from an
unknown
she has recently been subjected to
online death threats after she published
an article criticizing a disabled
activist's suicide
the scene also shows that her room
window is left open
karen park a london detective chief
inspector is watching a tv show when
suddenly gets a message and directly
comes to the crime scene
at there she meets blue colson and nick
shelton
blue is tech savvy in atdc the most
junior british police officer
in the criminal investigation department
and nick is a police officer that works
under karen's instruction
joe powers was found dead with her
throat cut at her house after the
horrendous post about a wheelchair woman
the crime scene looks like hell of a
struggle and they found her husband
slashed across the stomach and taken to
the hospital
the detectives can't find any points of
entry they find a cake sent from hater
and send it immediately to the
toxicologist
karen also commands her team to do a
full autopsy on the corpse
blue suspects her husband as a culprit
and karen thinks cutting the throat is
unusual
the next day karen finds nick and blue
watching at cctv and claims that no one
came in or out at the time of joe powers
death
it means that it's just her and her
husband in the house at that time
blue continues to collect every threat
or insult level to joe powers over the
previous 48 hours but karen claims that
internet stuff drifts off like whether
which people don't mean what they are
posting
suddenly nick approaches them and says
that the husband is already up and
talking
they proceed to the hospital to get his
testimony joe's husband says that he
heard his wife screaming and when he ran
into her room
he saw the woman was cutting her head in
her throat with a shard of glass
he tried to stop his wife and that was
when he got slashed
after that they finally can identify the
cake center's name
liza bahar who is a teacher and decide
to visit her
apparently liza bahar was one of the
netizens who posted a death threat to
joe powers with the death to hashtag
she explains that the hashtag is just a
game where you insert the name of
someone who's annoying
at that moment karen receives a report
from the toxicology that the cake is
clean
they give the teacher a caution for
offensive communication act and then
leave the school
in the office blue and karen are still
investigating joe's case when suddenly
nick interrupts the conversation and
mentions people on the internet are now
pissed off with tusk
who is the grammy award-winning rapper
in a talk show
he insults a nine-years-old fan who is
trying to emulate his dancing and
suggests the kid to stop dancing
while scrolling nick also finds one of
the hate posts with the death to hashtag
knight arrives tusk walks towards his
car and is offered a cigarette by one of
his pals
suddenly he falls while screaming and
holding his head like something has got
into it
after being picked up by ambulance he
still can't stop screaming
thus the nurse has to sedate him in the
hospital
he is brought to a room to undergo an
mri scan
however during the procedure the strong
magnet from the machine pulls out a
small b
device through his brain and eyeball
killing him instantly
the next day karen and blue visit a
doctor to see joe powers
autopsy result the doctor explains that
there is a hole
like a tiny tunnel that goes all the way
from her ear canal to deep in her brain
to be exact the part of the brain where
the hole ends is the dorsal posterior
insula
which is basically the brain's pain
center because of that
the victim will feel agony out of scale
and will do anything to stop that
surprisingly the doctor also found a
similar bee device from the tusk
incident which according to blue
is an adi or autonomous drone insect
from the granular project
they immediately head to granular
headquarters upon arrival
karen explains that the whole adi
project is funded by the government
they are welcomed by vanessa who then
leads them to rasmus one of the
higher-ups at the accompany
he explains that adi was essentially
created to replace near-extinct bees and
is solar-powered
adi also has a sensor which enables them
to navigate and detect flowers nearby
these b robots cover the whole uk and
can reproduce by duplicating themselves
and spreading out exponentially
after a short explanation about the
robot karen shows rasmus the adi that
caused joe powers death
he explains that this be robot is not
designed to kill and has got military
great encryption
which means that it has a very low
probability of being hacked
then he brings them to the control room
where they monitor all the hive online
blue tries to input joe powers as
postcode and thanks to that
they are able to identify that a be
robot near the journalist house suddenly
disappears from the control screen and
finds out that someone has hacked the
robot
when they command rasmus to trace the
culprit he tells the detectives that it
would be easier if he is not bothered by
people around
so he swaps number with blue to maintain
communication later
before they leave karen requests a list
of granular staff that had access to the
system
at the office karen hands over the list
to nick and asks him to root out anyone
interesting
apparently a national crime agency or
nca officer
sean lee approaches them as he found the
same bee robot that caused the death of
the rapper
in the middle of her investigation blue
reveals some similarities to both
victims
she links the death to a website
promoting a game named game of
consequences
where twitter users can vote to kill a
hated public figure with the victim
selected via the most votes with death
to hashtag and will be eliminated after
5 pm every day
the game was first published by a set of
duplicate bot accounts
it also seems like the number of users
participating in the game is growing
exponentially
after realizing how the game works the
group then tries to identify and protect
the next target
it's clara meades who had recently
tweeted a disrespectful selfie involving
a military war monument
at the moment she has already pocketed
880 votes on her name
before picking her up karen phones clara
to alert her about the situation and
tells him to pack up immediately
blue also contacts rasmus to monitor the
area around the potential victim area
with his futuristic car the ncaa agent
could turn every red light between
the tracks to green the group plans to
rescue clara to a secluded safe house
for a terrorist informant
upon arrival rasmus tells blue that he
picked up an attempted breach and one
adi just goes offline
they successfully rescue the potential
victim to the intended place
but unfortunately a lone ada which
initially targeted her manages to follow
them
rasmus from the control room informs the
group that he just loses control to all
be robots
suddenly thousands of the adi are
approaching the safe house and trying to
reach the victim
eventually a swarm of adi find every
unprotected opening in one adi finally
locates clara and burrows into her brain
clara dies in agony while the detectives
remain unharmed
after the horrendous event the group and
rasmus meet up and they have a little
conflict
blue deduces that the robots must find
their targets using advanced facial
recognition which is only possible if
granular has access to government
records
blue confronts lee and he is forced to
admit that the government is currently
using adi for mass public surveillance
as this was the only incentive to back
the project with the necessary funds to
make it successful
the usage of death to hashtag grows
rapidly after the public learns that the
game kills people
the situation becomes more critical as
tom the chancellor of exchequer
climbs to the top of the most hated list
in the meeting
he begs to shut down the system for one
day but
lee argues that if they shut it down he
will still be number one
so it will make no difference lee
proposes a plan to move the chancellor
to an underground bunker and knock out
every hive and bees within a 10-mile
radius
but the plan doesn't seem effective
karen interviews a former granular
employee who attempted suicide after
receiving online hate
who then reveals that her flatmate
garrett scholes an ex-granular employee
working on adi
saved her life her suspicion is
confirmed when the adi from joe powers
his brain turns out to contain a
manifesto written by garrett
the manifesto further states that he
wanted to force people to face the
consequences of their actions and not be
able to hide behind online anonymity
garrett had left the country six months
ago but a selfie taken on his phone
allows blue to trace his exact location
at the time
a raid on garrett's hideout results in
nothing as they are unable to catch the
culprit
but blue finds his unburned hard disk
and brings it to the office
when connected to the adi system it
downloads a list of everyone who has
ever used death to hashtag
the list contains the participants names
and faces
karen quickly works out that garrett
used hated public figures as bait
his plan was to use the adi to kill all
those on the list as the consequence of
their action in social media
blue and rasmus try to find a way to
shut down the system but karen thinks
garrett has led them into a trap and
that the deactivate function may
actually be the command to kill the
targets
against the detective's opinion lee
triggers the system
for a brief time it appears that
granular has regained control of the
system
but ultimately karen's theory is proven
correct and the adi are automatically
sent to kill the 300 000 people who use
death to hashtag
after the horrendous event karen
explains at the hearing that blue went
missing and is presumed to have
committed suicide
she is then allowed to leave as
nervously takes her place
karen herself has become a public hate
figure because of the case
at the end of the film she receives an
anonymous text from blue
who is still alive and secretly working
with the detective to track down
garrett's goals
blue has found him and tells karen they
have finally got him
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching